welcome to this video playing funk chest
video yeah I hope you have fun with this
chest video it's a new account from the
Netherlands and I'm going to play an
Enzo let's see now the e3 and queens two
other main moves really most popular all
levels yeah he says he likes my videos
okay oops thank him yep I am a recording
so keep a straight face you're on video
k is playing this this line with Bishop
d3 and 92 the iqp variation why doesn't
isolate it Queen part the iqp and the
the twist here is if you want to call it
up twist that is the night it's got the
night only to this is a very unusual
post for the night it normally is on f3
and possibly ready to join the the play
on on on e5 for example the night here
is some in comparison relatively passive
now but it is still an interesting line
and one reason is that it is some some
directed against the huebner variation
of the line in the classical that are
actually um recommend in my book and of
course play myself I mean I play all the
lines that I that I'm analyzing in the
book myself okay so he threatened Bishop
f6 and
and queen 87 mate but they have a
counter play here with be formed some
interesting he cannot you can take a now
on before word night before is a very
useful fork on the Queen and Bishop and
if he moves on the night it's not
quickly away I mean night a four is not
exactly great so I don't know if luke t
one was such a successful venture 94
night XD for losses apiece straightaway
term I don't know night night a form
it's not where you want to be a it's not
a great square yeah something like that
was maybe maybe necessary but what
exactly is going on now I can take the
five right also with this
and just claim that this is a pawn and
the point is a point is a pawn yeah it
really is upon let's see um I can take
on g5 this was my original intention and
I will do that just it's just nice yep
the bishop pair for nothing for no
compensation wait just one moment is
there now this is okay let's put this
pressure on the pawn until I have queen
bee six after which oh wait no it's okay
she takes it Bishop a sixth Stefan Utley
nice and be to hang some so white and
some white has some some problems now so
look 28 okay
yeah I wonder now I should i take on not
on b5 i mean at the end but yeah at the
end i always have this have the the
bishop a6 business it's very problematic
there should be three route 23 years
very nice windsor immediately
yeah so Brooke bh now is the move I
wonder like right away or they have to
play it right away it'll be it rook d7 I
can play Bishop f6 right and then there
is no move I hope the power of the
bishop pair yeah that's just an exchange
and it falls apart I'm i get be too if
you move through the night now this was
some some imprecisely move orders that
editor oops wait just wait now okay how
do I am foetus them the best way he
attacked from technical point of view
trading trading a look would be would be
helpful
or Bishop deform for rugby to also be
good
I want to trade I want to trade one rook
to reduce counterplay to to a minimum
now look on the second-ranked check and
f2 for this is checkmate even white
resigns yeah something something random
went wrong in the opening I'm not
completely sure where exactly the a 6b
five setup is very normal in this in
this line sometimes even this is an
interesting idea but it didn't didn't
get that farm there should be seven is
normal Queen III also looks normal g6
and I think may be here round here he
has to do something something
differently the computer wants to go
before and says about equal am probably
like this that makes lots of sense
trying to prevent my before but you
should never forget this is an isolated
queen pond and I mean this this I have
some idea have pressurized this pawn it
it's not so easy for him to get any any
attack going it's a very safe King so to
be honest I don't believe in this slide
that much it it's not bad for white of
course but if black knows what he's
doing yo I should be okay in the game I
got this in and interior well it's just
a pawn but can you do why good position
94 is probably what he has to do it
looks ugly but maybe still the way to go
yeah yes to do that
I'm wondering here that's interesting
the computer wants to play this move
this is a funny funny point very nice
but this is also leading to a very nice
position for black web I'm just clearly
better now and then the penis is
decisive okay well thanks for watching